俺が大学2年生だった時
授業を受けるためにに大学の階段を登っていた
目の前のちょっとキレイな女子大生の人が歩いていたんですけど
スカートがリュックに挟まってて
パンツまる見えで歩いてたんですよ。
（沈黙）
俺は悩んだ！
果たして彼女にそのことを言っていいのか！
もし俺がそれを言っちゃうと
「パンツ見たよ」ってことを断定的に説明してることになる
けど言わないと！
彼女はそのままリュックにスカートを挟んだまま
授業を受ける教室まで行き
もっと大勢の人にパンツを見られてしまう
俺は悩んだ結果…
恥ずかしくて言えませんでした…。
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです
世の中には、言ってはいけないこともあると思います
いや、マジでね
言わないほうが幸せなことも多いかもしれない
でもそれを言うべきなのかもしれない
そこを決めるのはやっぱ皆さん次第です
何が正しいか僕からは言えませんが
言っていいことと悪いこと
言わなくていい真実
言ったほうがいい真実がある
そこの見極め非常に難しいところなんですけども
今回僕は今からちょっと東京に行かなきゃいけないんですけど
この僕の家から、東京の僕の事務所まで行く間に
僕は両鼻に歯ブラシをブッ刺していこうと思います
ミスったんでしょう
寝ぼけてて…
新幹線に乗り、電車に乗り、タクシーに乗り！
事務所まで行きます
六本木の
非常に難しいことだと思うんで
鼻に歯ブラシが入ってて
ひょっとしたら花粉対策かもしれない
ひょっとしたらそういう趣味の方かもしれない
はたまた…
パーなのかもしれない
果たしてそのことをね言っていいのか言わない方がいいのかっていうちょっと皆さんのね…
ちょっぽじゃねぇ。
ちょっと皆さんのこう地域調査的なね、実験的にやってみようと思います。
もう時間ないからもう行きます！東京！
では行こう！
（BGM）
お願いしま～す
はじめ）いい天気ですね～
運転手）ねぇ～。フッフ。
（くしゃみ）
（BGM）
（鼻をすする）
はじめ）はい、ありがとうございま～す。
はじめ）ありがとうございました。
券売機）いらっしゃいませ
券売機）ありがとうございました
（BGM）
（オルゴールBGM）
（新幹線到着チャイム）
（BGM）
（電車到着チャイム）
（くしゃみ）
（BGM）
男性）あの…
男性）歯ブラシが…
男性）鼻に刺さってます
はじめ）ありがとうございます
はじめ）あ～すみませんありがとうございます
事務所の男性）お疲れ様でーす
はじめ）あーわかりました。
はじめ）小笑くらいでしたね